In the question hash string,
we have to determine which of the following statements are true.
Let's go through the statements 1 by 1.
The first statement says the number of string comparisons done to look up a keyword
that is not a key in the hash table may be less than the number needed to look up a keyword
that is a key in the hash table.
As this turns out, this is actually a true statement.
In order to show it, we need an example,
so let me give you an example dictionary with 3 buckets and 3 keywords in here.
I'm not showing the values because they don't really matter for this example.
It could be the case that if we search for "Batman"
our hash function takes us to bucket 0
and then we have to compare between "Andy," "is," and finally "Batman."
So that would be 3 string comparisons.
Let's say we search for "Irvin" and that brings us to bucket 2.
There's nothing in bucket 2, so there's no comparisons to be made.
This is an example where it actually takes more comparisons
to look up something in the hash table than it does to look up something not in the hash table.
Statement 2 says we should expect the time to look up most keywords in the hash table
will decrease as we increase the number of buckets.
And with a good hash function this is true.
Let's say we have a hash table with only 2 buckets.
If we have a good hash function, the number of keywords in each bucket is the same.
And so the average number of comparisons is going to be half the size of a bucket
in order to look up a keyword in the hash table.
If we double the number of buckets, the average lookup time is decreasing significantly.
And with a good hash function the time is going to decrease even more.
Statement 3 says it is always better to have more buckets in a hash table.
This is a pretty strong statement,
as indicated by the use of the word always,
and it's really because of that word that the statement is false.
There's really 2 good reasons.
The first reason is because changing the number of buckets,
be it more or less, changes where keywords hash to.
It could be the case that with 2 buckets I have a good distribution.
But if I add a third bucket, the hash function is such
that everything lands in that new bucket.
We choose hash functions carefully so that this is less likely,
but depending on the keywords you're using, this is still possible.
And the second reason is memory.
I could have an arbitrarily long hash table,
but they can use a lot of space, especially if there are a few keywords that go into it.
Real-world implementations of hash tables try to shoot for a ratio
between the number of buckets they have and the number of keywords,
increasing the number of buckets accordingly
as the number of keywords in the hash table decrease and increase.
Statement 4 says the time to look up a keyword in the hash table
is always less than the time it would take in a linear time list (as used in Unit 4).
So the question is, is the lookup time always less
than the lists that we've been using previously?
And as you might suspect, this statement is false.
We're going to show that by giving an example hash table.
If I have a hash table where 3 keywords all go in bucket 1,
if I want to look up the keyword "Batman," I'm going to go to bucket 1
and iterate through each item in this bucket until I find "Batman."
That's essentially the same as a normal list where we just start from the beginning
without doing any kind of hash function
and just go through each item 1 by 1 searching for "Batman."